Dean is an Indiana hi Dean how are you
I'm all right
large pink we hear you too what's up Oh
looking like that I'm going through a
divorce
talking with an attorney and basically
my wife is going to be entitled to a
half of a half of my pension because
it's a thirty-year-old pension but we've
only been married just shot 15 years
it's going to mount about 15 grand it
would be her half of a half but it's a
municipal pension so it's going to be
structured out or I'll have to just make
payments what would be a fair cash offer
on a 15 grand structured settlement like
that well the the technical way to
calculate it would be to figure out when
she would actually receive it when would
she begin receiving it well the twenty
second here to go two ways I'm 49 years
old
I can't retire you know I mean I'll have
my points and when I'm 54 yeah so I
could actually start growing there but I
don't plan on retiring that okay but
that and that actually she would get
this there's no pension they allow no
early withdrawals for nothing I think
every other 401k does but I've been a
municipal employee all these years I may
allow withdrawals for no reason right
well if you have an investment advisor
they can put it into a financial
calculator and what you would say is
you're going to get $15,000 12 years
from now or whatever the number is right
and you're actually not even going to
get it then you're going to get payments
for the next 15 years beginning 12 years
from now or whatever it is but those
factors and they can put in a discount
right I'd probably use about a 6%
interest rate because that's what most
of the pensions grow at and then that
discount rate would tell you what the
present value of that lump sum is or
what the present value
of that future stream of payments is and
that would be the appropriate discounted
amount I doubt that that is going to be
very appealing to her it's gonna be a
very low number okay so if I were in
your shoes I'd probably would offer I
mean I'm thinking that's gonna end up
being three thousand bucks oh yeah that
that's the present value of her
receiving a stream of payments from a
fifteen thousand dollar portion
beginning twelve years from now and
she'd probably get the payments for
fifteen or twenty years so it's not
gonna mount a squat as what it amounts
to instead if I were in your shoes I
would rather have the clean break I'd
probably offer a five seven thousand
dollars which is probably a lot more
than that's technically worth fifty
cents on the dollar bid nice offer okay
well I was thinking ten would be real
fair so they're very it's it's your yeah
I mean you can actually get someone I
can't do it here on the air because it's
a it takes a few minutes to put all
those numbers into the into the
calculator and make it spit back out
your answer but I would use tell your
financial guy that put it in a financial
calculator what payments would she
receive over what period of time
beginning when and you that will tell
you what to put in there and the
payments beginning at this stage and
then they bring back the value as of
today in other words if if she had that
seven thousand or that three thousand
dollars and invested it today and it on
her own it would create more money than
seven thousand dollars for sure would
create more money than this pension will
create for her because you would invest
it it would it would grow between now
and twelve years from now or whenever
you would retire and then it would
create payments from then on out and it
would create more money so it's good for
her to take it as a lump sum it's good
for you if you take it as a lump sum for
just from the simplicity of your life
and the cleanliness of the clean break
and a divorce and so yeah I would be
generous with my offer seven to ten
thousand but I think you can make a real
strong mathematical case that that is
prompt you
put it in calculator but I'm guessing
it's gonna be twice what it's worth
which is what its gonna take because
she's not gonna believe you it takes
someone in the financial world to
actually grasp that whole thing and work
it out and she's just gonna think you're
trying to screw her over that's all it
is in the divorce it just changes
everything everything is all about the
emotion then and working it through so
hey good question we appreciate you
joining us I'm sorry you're going
through this brother